hello commander welcome to GameSpot's
three-part series on XCOM - last month
of packs GameSpot got dispensed of time
with lead designer jig Solomon to talk
about the history of the franchise its
2012 rebirth and his plans for XCOM -
thanks mysterious stranger I'll pick it
up from here over the next three days
we're going to explore all these avenues
but today we focus on the past I've
played every XCOM at least the ones that
have been released and though you may be
familiar with the original game you
might not realize that this is a
franchise that's been kicked about more
than a can in a prison yard it's had
some wonderful games and some
appallingly terrible ones so let's dive
into it commander today on part one the
history of X call
the seeds of XCOM were sown in laser
squad released on various home computers
in 1988 designed by British programmer
Julian Gollop this turn-based war game
had you take on a series of missions
ranging from rescue missions to
assassinations and firefights
it was well received and later that year
Julian and his brother Nick started
their own development studio mythos
games and coming off the success of
laser squad they once again turned the
turn-based strategy at first they wanted
to release a sequel to laser squad with
the games publisher baltimore-based
microprose wanted something fresh Methos
first real game was released in 1994 and
it's fair to say the lexicon was an
instant classic
UFO enemy unknown or XCOM UFO defenses
it was titled in north america is a
strategy game in which you manage an
organization responsible for protecting
human race from an extraterrestrial
threat it's sort of two games mashed
together the first base management
simulator that has you building bases
buying interceptor ships conducting
research and lobbying for funds from the
various world powers from here you
decide what threats to investigate and
which UFOs to shoot down and once you've
down the UFO and equipped your response
team the game swaps into a turn-based
strategy game this is where the bulk of
your time with ex-con will be spent the
game is turn-based meaning that you and
the aliens take turns in moving and
these movements are limited by a set
number of action points every action you
take costs points moving shooting
reloading crouching even priming
grenades so you have to be careful to
ensure you're spending your AP wisely it
plays like a game of chess where every
move is as much about creating offensive
opportunities as it is ensuring your
pieces are safe from opposition attack
once you've made your moves to game
swaps control to the aliens and you have
to watch is the aliens Scott are about
in the darkness emerging to take pop
shots at your fragile troopers and
reacting to your tactics
XCOM was also incredibly atmospheric
distant alien noises and human screams
coupled with creepy music and the
ominous fog of war meant that even
stepping out of your ship required
bravery soldiers could be killed in an
instant doing so often caused new
recruits to freak the hell out and flee
and shoot wildly tactical advantages
could be flipped in an instant meaning
you never really felt like you were in
full control
I asked Jake what it was about the first
game that made it so memorable um so the
original XCOM I got that when I was a
senior in high school I played them
obsessively and if you play that you
know I have so many memories of sitting
there alone at night it's very spooky
game you know and so you just I just
have many of these memories just me
sitting for the computer Greg and I my
art director we went and looked back at
it recently and it's you know it's like
340 by 260 or 3 and you're like oh how
did that work like how was I so
terrified but you've read so much into
you know it was very hard to understand
like and so it was like you didn't know
why things were having it felt like a
real simulation I think that's what it
was when you play it it feels like a
simulation more than probably any
strategy game today that you know the
game sort of felt like it was its own
little world running so yeah and it was
spooky and it was you know awesome you
get attached to your soldiers you know
it's always been my favorite game XCOM
was tough and complex it was a game that
mirrored real-life combat harsh
demanding and ambivalent to your
struggles it was also beloved by gamers
and they weren't the only ones who
wanted more like a pro's asta gallops to
do it again in under six months but
mythos decided to pass and jump onto the
third game in the series apocalypse so
the responsibility to make the six-month
sequel landed on a UK studio run by
microprose it took them 12 months to
complete it but completed they did in
exactly the type of fashion you'd expect
they took the old game and stuck on some
new textures XCOM terror from the deep
was set decades after the first game
where you fight a recently awoken alien
race who crashed into the earth 65
million years prior killing all the
dinosaurs quite why you have to fight
them underwater is never really
explained but as all the alien equipment
you researched in the previous games
doesn't work in salt water
it proves as a handy plot device also
when you end again you accidentally
plunged the earth into an apocalypse
terror from the deep wasn't much of a
revolution from the first game but it
was still fun it was harder and
generally considered a rather tired
sequel to a wonderful game XCOM to me
UFO defense I suppose in Europe it was
enemy Unknown that's right um but to me
that was the game that resonated with me
the most because it was set on earth
because in there from the Reapers under
the water but you could look at X column
and you could say okay I reckon that's a
field that's a forum I had this
emotional connection all this stuff oh
I'm in a city now and so then when they
went under the water one the game was
really difficult terribly real difficult
but it was interesting how once it went
under the water and all these crazy
aliens then I just didn't feel a strong
connection to the places and so an
apocalypse was awesome you know it was
awesome but it was it looks really
sci-fi that gradualism while terror from
the deep was being made out of house
mythos were working on the third game
apocalypse this was set a century after
the end of the second game as humanity
has been forced to settle into mega
cities to escape the global meltdown of
the planets ecosystem released in 1997
it was quite a departure from the main
series featuring new graphics interface
and adoptive enemy AI and even allows
you to play the game in real time or in
the traditional turn-based mode after
apocalypse is released however mythos
were worried that they'd lose the
lawsuit if they tried to retain the IP
in court so they struck a licensing deal
for apocalypse and handed over the XCOM
license to microprose if you talk about
any other's past that I don't have that
much experience I'm an interceptor
enforcer yeah I don't I suppose I should
explain you were so close to being
complete and so you've yet to undergo a
full subsystem stress test I see jake
draws a blank here for a good reason the
next decade of ex-con games has almost
been lost to history but it contains a
bunch of games terrible review scores
and an IP being fenced from company to
company the first game XCOM interceptor
made by microprose now that they own the
IP was released in 1998 it was a flight
sim mixed with the usual base management
stuff set before apocalypse it had a
completely different tone to the
original three games but loads of
bizarre pop-culture references and full
of the type of humor
you're embarrassing uncle would make
over Thanksgiving dinner after the
release of interceptor Hasbro the toy
makers bought the struggling Microprose
in turn taking over the XCOM brand with
an eye to assimilating it into its
various toy ranges Hasbro Interactive's
first attempt at this was 1999
XCOM first alien invasion a play by male
multiplayer game now if you've never
heard of play by male multiplayer it's
essentially the email equivalent of
playing a game of chess over the mail if
that wasn't bad enough Hasbro wasn't
done yet soon afterwards the struggling
company canceled two XCOM games they had
adopted in the microprose takeover
Alliance a first-person shooter and
Genesis a strategy game set in a world
familiar to fans of the original game
neither was close enough to complete and
financial trouble method Hasbro
to sell something quick so they took
assets from both games and then cobbled
them together to make 2001 XCOM enforcer
a by-the-numbers third-person shooter
would barely a thematic or tonal link to
the original games I played a bunch of
it a couple of years ago and it's mad
just take a look yourself the alien
invaders draw nearer with every
nanosecond
bleating enforcer finish charging up get
out there and do what you were made to
do
eradicate don't alien soon afterwards
the assets of Hasbro interactive were
sold to French developer Infogrames an
ex-con became stuck in a game of IP
tennis for a couple of years in 2004
Infogrames now rebranded Atari sold the
rights to the civilization franchise to
take to interactive the struggling
company then sold back the digital
rights to a bunch of Hasbro properties
the following year transformers in My
Little Pony and that same year in June
of 2005 take-two interactive bought a
bunch more IPS from Atari one of them
being XCOM take two went right to work
on their IP in April 2010 2k Marin
developers of Bioshock - an answer they
were working on a new XCOM and a month
later at e3 we saw the game entitled
XCOM was a first-person shooter set in
the 50s where at least according to the
trailer use the variety weapons to kill
a bunch of weird black goo sadly for 2k
the trailer was not well received by
fans of the series who are pining for a
classic XCOM game but little did they
know one was already in development you
see in 2005 the same year take to it
acquired the ex-con license a year after
they had acquired the civilizations
license it also acquired fair access
games the studio set up by former
Microprose developers Sid Meier Jeff
Briggs and Brian Reynolds who had left
the company to release some of the best
strategy games of all time
Alpha Centauri and civilization the
stage was set for the ultimate comeback
while 2k Marines XCOM game would change
into a third-person shooter the Bureau
XCOM declassified came out in August
2013
behind closed doors the keys to a
classic XCOM were being handed to a
young designer and a lifelong found the
series his name is Jake I'm going to
talk to him about it tomorrow and that's
where we leave today's story make sure
you check back tomorrow to see how Jake
and his team at Firaxis took a series
that have been kicked from pillar to
post and gave it the rebirth it deserves
see you that commander
you